Elon Musk bought Twitter because he used
Twitter it's as simple as that and he
was infuriated by Twitter's effort to
silence people on the internet that's
how strongly he believed in free speech
he paid 44 billion dollars and
immediately lost tens of billions of
dollars doing it and when he took over
and looked behind the curtain he
discovered Twitter was really a tool of
the global Intel agencies to spy on
people and emit propaganda here it is
[Music]
you bought Twitter famously you've got a
lot of other businesses
and a lot going on yes you said you
bought it because you believe in speech
Free Speech you've had a lot of hassle
since you bought it and retrospect was
it worth buying it
I mean it remains to be seen as to
whether this was uh financially smart
currently it is it is not uh you know we
just revalued the company at less than
half of the acquisition price yes
um
um no my timing was terrible for for
when the uh offer was made because it
was uh you know right before advertising
plummeted and um you got the high water
mark I noticed yeah
yeah so I must be a real genius here
um my my timing is amazing
um because since I've had a border for
at least twice as much as it should have
been bought for
um but some things are Priceless and um
so the the whether I lose money or not
that is a secondary issue compared to uh
ensuring the uh strength of democracy uh
and free speech is the Bedrock of a
functioning democracy yes um and any the
speech needs to be as uh transparent and
truthful as possible
um so we've got a huge push on Twitter
to be as truthful as possible we've got
this community notes feature which is
great it is great it is awesome yeah and
it's like I saw it this morning yeah it
was far more honest than the New York
Times it's great yeah we put a lot of
effort to ensuring that Community notes
does not get gamed or or have biases it
is simply cares about what is the most
accurate thing
um
and you know sometimes truth can be a
little bit elusive but you could but you
can still aspire to get closer to it yes
you know and so
um
and I think the the effect of uh
Community notes uh is more powerful than
people may realize because once people
know that they could get noted
um you know Community noted on Twitter
then uh they'll think so more carefully
about what they say uh there are likely
it's basically it's an encouragement to
be more truthful and less deceptive when
you jumped into this though when you
bought it did you understand well
clearly you understood its importance
you wouldn't have bought it
uh Twitter yes right but it's not the
biggest but it's the most important in
the social media companies but did you
understand the kind of ferocity you'd be
facing the attacks you'd be facing from
Power centers in the country
um I thought there'd probably be some um
negative reactions yes
[Laughter]
so I'm not I'm sure everyone would not
be pleased with the uh with with it um
but um
at the end of the day
you know if if the public is happy with
it that's what matters
um and the public will speak with their
actions although I mean if if they find
truth Twitter to be useful they will use
it more and if they find it to be not
useful I will use it less if they find
it to be the best source of truth I
think they will use it more
you know no there's obviously a lot of
um organizations that are used to having
sort of unfettered influence uh on
Twitter
um that no longer have that New York
Times have their of their badge this
morning and then you called them
diarrhea okay you did you did I'm just
I'm just quoting you
describe their
area
I said it was the Twitter Twitter
equivalent of diarrhea okay it's not
literally diarrhea but no it's a you
know it's a metaphor um
but an accurate one
um so I mean if you look at the uh at NY
Times Twitter feed is unreadable uh it's
like because what they do is they tweet
every single article even the ones that
are uh boring even ones that don't make
it into the paper so uh so it's just
non-stop is it zillion tweets a day with
no uh you know they really should just
be saying like what are the top tweets
yeah like what are the what are the what
are the big stories of the day uh I
don't know put out like
10 or something you know so it's a
number that's manageable as opposed to
right now if you if you were to follow
it uh NY at nytimes on Twitter you're
going to get barraged with like hundreds
of tweets a day yeah um and your whole
feed will be filled with NY Times so
um that that's that's this is something
I would recommend actually for oral
Publications uh which is uh for your
primary feed
um only put out your best stuff like I
think I know a thing or two about how to
use Twitter because uh you know it was
the most interacted with account on the
whole system uh before the acquisition
before the acquisition closed I didn't
have the most number of followers so I
had the most number of interactions and
so I clearly know something about how to
use Twitter you know people's attention
is limited so just make sure you put the
stuff that's most important there so
because you know you and people like you
do interact on Twitter
it's obviously enormously powerful in
shaping public opinion it's where a lot
of ideas and Trends are incubated yeah
you know that's why
it's also a magnet for Intel agencies
from around the world and yes one of the
things we learned after you started
opening the books is that they were
exerting influence from within Twitter
I mean it was absurd
um
did you know that going in no
since I've been a heavy Twitter user
since 2009
um my it's it's sort of like I'm in The
Matrix I mean I can see
like things do things feel right do they
not feel right what what tweets am I
being shown as recommended uh
like I I get a feel like what accounts
are making comments uh where are the
comments uh eerily similar yeah
um and uh and then you look at the
account and it's just obviously a fake
photo and uh you know uh that it's just
obviously a bot cluster uh over and over
again so I started to get like just more
and more uneasy about the the Twitter
situation I thought I was starting to
feel like something's brought in the
state of Denmark here there's
so much feels wrong about the platform
it seemed to be just drifting in a
I I couldn't place it exactly just ahead
of it felt like it was drifting in a bad
Direction so then I was like and and my
conversations with the board and
management seem to confirm my
intuition about that but basically I was
convinced these guys do not care about
fixing Twitter uh and and uh and
I had a bad feeling about where I was
headed based in the conversations
conversations I had with him so then I
was like
you know what I I
I'll try acquiring it and see if that's
see if acquiring it is is possible
um
now I didn't have enough cash to acquire
it so I would need you know support from
others um from some of the existing
investors I would also need like a lot
of debt and um so it wasn't clear to me
with a an acquisition would succeed but
I thought I would try and uh
ultimately it did succeed anyway here we
are but when you got there and all of a
sudden you own it and all the data on
the service belongs to you and it
belongs to the people in my view but yes
but but you can see what I guess and you
can see what they've been doing and you
can see who's been working there you you
were shocked to find out that various
Intel agencies were affecting its
operations uh the the degree to which uh
various government agencies had
effectively had full access to
everything that was going on on Twitter
uh blew my mind I was not aware of that
would that include people's DMs
uh yes
yes because the dams are not encrypted
so one of the first you know one of the
things that we're about to release is
ability to encrypt your DM that's pretty
heavy duty though because a lot of
well-known people reporters talking to
their sources government officials the
rich people in the world they're dming
each other
and the Assumption obviously was
incorrect but was that that's private
but that was being read by various
governments uh yeah that seems to be yes
scary uh yes it is uh so like I said
we're moving to
um have the DMS be optionally encrypted
I mean you know there's like a lot of DM
conversations which are you know just
chatting with friends it's not not
important
um it's hopefully coming out later this
month but no later than next month uh is
the ability to toggle encryption on or
off so if you if you are in a
conversation you think is sensitive you
can just toggle encryption on and then
no one on Twitter can see what you're
talking about like I could put a gun to
my head and I couldn't I couldn't tell I
couldn't
can I still not uh see your DMs that
should be that's the acid test yes
um
and that's how that's that's how it
should be if you want your have you had
complaints from various governments
about doing this
I haven't had Direct complaints to me
I've had sort of like some indirect
complaints I think people are a little
concerned about
complaining to me directly in case I
tweet about it
you know
uh they're like oh uh so they're sort of
trying to be more roundabout than that
you know I mean if if I got something
that was uh unconstitutional from the US
government I would say my reply would be
to send them a copy of the you know
First Amendment
and just say like what part of this are
we getting wrong
you have a lot of government you have a
lot of government what part of this are
we getting wrong please tell me I mean
it's a pretty no I'm just saying but
you're kind of exposed in your other
businesses so this is uh just in case
reviewers aren't following this
this is not you're not just like a
journalist taking a stand on behalf of
the First Amendment you're a guy with
big government contracts giving the
finger to the government do you think
um
Twitter will be as Central to this
presidential campaign as it was in the
last several I think it will play a
significant role in elections not just
domestically but internationally the
goal of new Twitter is to be
um as fair and even-handed as possible
so not favoring any political
ideology but just
um
yeah being being uh being fair at all
why doesn't Facebook do this I know that
Zuckerberg has said and I take him at
face value that he I well I
well I'd sway that he is a kind of
old-fashioned liberal who doesn't like
to censor he has but he you know like
why wouldn't a company like that take
the stand that you have taken it was
pretty rooted in American traditional
political custom you know for free
speech
my understanding is that
um Zuckerberg spent a 400 million
dollars in the last election normally in
a get out the boat campaign but really
fundamentally in support of Democrats is
that accurate or not accurate that is
accurate does that sound unbiased to you
no it doesn't yes so you don't see hope
that Facebook will approach this as
a a
non-aligned Orbiter you've allowed
Donald Trump back on Twitter he hasn't
taken you up on your offer because he's
got his own thing right do you think he
will go back on Twitter
well that's that's obviously up to him
um you know my job is to uh I you know I
take
the freedom of speech
just very seriously so it's
um you know I didn't I didn't vote for
Donald Trump I actually voted for Biden
I'm not saying I'm a huge fan of Biden
because I I would think that would
probably be inaccurate uh but
um
you know we have difficult choices to
make in these residential uh elections
it's not I I I would prefer
frankly that we we put someone it's just
a normal person as president a normal
person with common sense uh and whose
values are smack in the middle of the
country you know just
you know Sarah the normal distribution
and uh I think they'll do that that
would be great yeah I think we have made
maybe being president
not that much fun you know it should be
jolly Frank
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight